stuart ramsey chief correspondent was of
course reporting from kabul airport
since the 12th of august and saw this
all unfolding stuart um
stuart tell us more
yeah so um
we have been there we were there
yesterday this is exactly where we've
been working for the last uh few days
it is kabul airport but i think people
have to understand it it's it's not
quite the airport itself it's a it's a
road that runs along the side of it
and in that road is a hotel which is now
the compound where all of the british
evacuation effort has been taking place
outside of the gates of that compound
leads to the beginning of the military
side of the airport you basically come
out of the gate and turn right
that
area
to the right of that
was a canal and this was one of the two
areas by which people could come in to
have their processing um start
it was very chaotic it was very
difficult the brits are slightly further
down but they man right up to the
beginning of that
canal which is about 50 meters away from
the from the uh british position and the
compound they've been working from and
in front of them
with the canal with barbed wire with
walls are american soldiers and soldiers
from all over the world and they have
been
trying to process people
through that position and there's a huge
queue of people from behind them now
people come into that area trying to get
through
the road itself is completely blocked
off so it is only by walking they can
get there
um and the huge numbers means that they
haven't been able to check people coming
through they come with their bags
because some of them are legitimate
many of them are legitimate have a right
to get through so the bags are coming
with them all the families etc it has
always been identified as a very
dangerous point we've thought about it
we've talked to it we talked to the
british military and american military
about it and they've always known it was
dangerous because they don't know who
was in that area
so we believe today from uh we're
talking to our contacts
on the ground to the military as well is
that a suicide bomber has come into that
canal area and has exploded his bomb
there are huge number of people and
there will be casualties amongst them
for certain because it it's impossible
not there is a high wall that leads out
of the canal which would be always
guarded
mainly by american soldiers
we believe that
some are injured and we have been told
that some are dead but we do not know
that now but this was a a choke point a
very dangerous one we don't believe it
would be the taliban we think it is
islamic state and their affiliate with
uh within afghanistan
um there will be casualties for certain
we then heard there was a um what was
described as a firefight to us but we
don't know that could have just been
soldiers firing it could have been other
people firing because it often is like
that when you have uh bomb attacks they
can be very very chaotic i've been in
them that is what they're like there are
reports of a second bomb which would
then suggest we're talking about a
sophisticated attack with a
bomb
gunfire bomb that's fairly standard and
as people run away they get hit by the
second uh bomb or if medical staff or
more soldiers arrive that's the second
bomb now that is only being reported at
the moment but that is sort of usually
how it works if it is a sophisticated
attack
what effect this has
on the whole processing system i think
my suspicion is it could almost be the
end of it because the risk will not go
away it'll actually increase
and
we already know that some countries had
already said the risk is too high and
we're withdrawing anyway
that could be end of it is a hugely
significant event because of that alone
days earlier than the expected
withdrawal which in many ways regardless
of dates was going to be quicker than
probably most afghans who were trying to
get out uh would have hoped but i think
that might be the the effect of this
we'll have to see of course but the the
the main airport itself
by the pentagon standards still has
about ten thousand people in it that
have to be um uh processed um that is
possible i suppose
but they will have to withdraw and they
will have to protect uh the airport now
the airport is absolutely vast and you
can imagine it's not as big as heathrow
but think about the number of people you
would need to protect heathrow or any
big airport that anyone has traveled for
it's vast very very difficult to do so
they'll have to draw in further uh it
means that the whole of this relief
effort the whole of the evacuation is is
probably coming to an end